one day the women came to me threw up
meeting I had an employment without a
hundred women in my organization and
they said you know why we never we know
why we are never promoted when we never
get the job we always considered and
everybody wants to promote women but we
never get the job and do you know why
and I was I was here on this stage and a
hundred women you know this you know I
thought it was a good guy I thought we
were doing our best and everything
what possible answer yeah we know why
cuz we're never the best qualified
understand and I said why is it well you
have your best day you said we have the
same education men do but when the job
comes up were always considered and we
looked at the two sets of experience and
the woman never has as good experience
because they never get the really
leading-edge projects to work on they're
always working on these other projects
and because we always get we get project
nobody wants us to fail so is give us
they seem to always give us the the
second-best project the safe project cuz
they never because we don't have enough
women they want the helping us by giving
us these safe projects we never get the
other projects what do we do how do we
fix this and I knew I couldn't go back
to the department has they give women
rescue project doesn't work but this is
example of something there's nothing to
do with precision this is the up my
other side which is the wheeling and
dealing site and so I said right a
person and I thought of this immediately
I said right a personal business plan
personal business plan what's that I
said put a horizontal line on a piece of
paper put down a number which is the
value of Majan that your project
whatever is your going to do is a
success and give it a number could be
dollars or years of your life I give
five years if I'm going to say your
medical student I give 10 years of my
life to cure cancer or whatever it is so
you get a number multiply it by the
probability and divide it by the cost so
if that's a big number do it's a small
number don't do it well it turned out
that's a very imprecise thing to do and
nobody knows exactly what the value is
and nobody knows exactly what the cost
isn't you don't know what the
probability is every one of those that
guess but in the process of doing is
they first went to the department and
the partment has came back and said we
don't know its value so I said go ask
the customer who is it who has been a
benefit go ask the beneficiary of this
how much it's worth to the beneficiary
so we don't know who the beneficiary is
and all the women began to say you mean
you're giving me a job whose value you
don't know who the beneficiary isn't
don't know they started asking that
question and within three years I think
we had five or six or ten promotions and
then my job today is held by one of the
women that got promoted at that time so
that's another side in some way that's
that's an example of what you do when
you're later
you